set between the third and fourth John
Wick film its second spin-off project
ballerina will star Anna De armis as a
Deadly Assassin while Kiana Reeves will
return in an extended Cameo other actors
scheduled to return to brief appearances
include Angelica Houston as the Director
Ian mcshain as Winston and Lance reck as
chirone in one of his final performances
film not long before his death in early
2023 Norman Reedus Gabriel burn and
Catalina sandino Moreno will also star
Len WIS men of Total Recall Fame will be
directing ballerina and thanks to urging
from Star at the armis Emerald fennel
writer director of promising young woman
is joining original screenwriter Shay
Hatton to work on the script while we
don't have an official plot synopsis we
know it will follow a female assassin
looking for revenge against those who
killed her family ballerina stands to be
another First Rate action thriller and
if the John Wick films are anything to
go by it'll certainly blow audiences
away when it releases on June 7th 2024